at the late start I was simply too
shocked to have white and white against
haga why am I good white thats its kind
of impossible but I got white usually I
just have to play the black side of b3
not this time ok um is going for some
kind of old Indian Kings Indian mix why
check by nominee yeah I really think
that this is a very good position for
white we'll see what happens night h5
yes so mibg 3m prevent night air flow
and see what happens hmm ok King h8 what
is the idea of this move I have no idea
hmm f5 ok let's do this to fight against
their five yeah okay I can just go back
usually this kind of night f4 movies is
not any good because it just hangs in
midair and doesn't it doesn't do much
and one point you would have to move it
again ok what is he up to some be five
ok let's let's prevent that
hmm yeah the question is to take or not
to take i think i'll take ok taking f
form click each floor so that is
probably not particularly great check
out for h5 because f4 he weakens his
light squares a lot
yeah G for that position is very very
nice forward he goes back i play Bishop
d3 then he has to play a form some kind
of desperation move otherwise is
strategically already completely lost he
has to play some D for now hope hope for
the best ok so what now g 5 h 5 23 is
also good let's go clean up three and
now supreme of h5m
nice pieces are exceptionally bad yeah
f4 was yeah don't think you can play
that move unless he can play a 40m for
some some kind of craziness other than
that that's not not not playable at all
okay teen aged 5 let's see how to how to
do this check if the check here should
be okay anyway just with a chicken and
see he cannot really move much dabbling
on the edge file would be would be nice
for example
GG 6 I don't see a totally clear win
okay let's just bring more pieces into
the attack
d 6 is falling I think oh this one okay
it should be a bit much here
see no more fear Bishop g7 that my i can
go yet
yes to take on h7 more or less I don't
don't really see anything else
9 f8 the screen f7
I'm a piece up at the antium black
resigns yeah here I think this is this
is a borderline positions of any way for
black but i think around here 96 gin and
here he goes f form he has to play evil
after that otherwise and it's just rity
giclee lost you just have to he has to
go E for here now maybe take take a form
and this is not not clear at all mean
age five and g5 h6 I don't know Bishop
deform that's just a wild position may
be here the computer likes white
initially at least which is not yeah
okay White's position is very open here
I was taking some risk there but it's
absolutely this is not that that just
losers after g4 engine is on plus to
point something already you cannot
sacrifice here and now the position is
similarly toast may be here if all I
would have played euphoria just just to
do anything whatever okay after the
blockade why this giant white is
crashing through rook age six also was a
good move here and that's that's nothing
that can be can be held in any anyway no
that's a nice move by the engine check
check and checkmate and made okay
but this was winning we need tons of
material and a general point yeah I
think that this closed center here with
the fianchetto and then what yeah nine
th five is good otherwise I go g4
immediately but I also think that this
isn't particularly great the clothes
Center has some yeah means that black
has very little counter play in that
area of the board and run the King side
it's very difficult to get get something
going it's just uh yeah it's just more
comfortable why this position okay well
thanks for watching